thank you thanks so much for having me
sorry but the last some fonts didn't
transfer and things were getting cut off
so in fact they still are so very glad
to be here in case there's any tweeting
that you'd like to do these are some of
the these are the key identifier for me
personally and for my team so so I work
at the New York Public Library and I run
a department called digital library in
labs and what we basically do is we're
looking at the entire digital life cycle
of our collections and my collections
I'm mostly talking about the kind of
rare and unique materials the library
has collected over the years less
focused on the secondary materials in
our in our research collections more the
kind of the archives and special and
rare material our team works on the
digitization of collections the
description of collections so they can
really talk to the web usually at the
item level ideally and then the use
engagement with an enrichment of
collections and Maya Richmond you'll see
what I'm talking about more later but
sort of adding new information or mining
new information from the collections
once they've kind of become digital so
in other words we're kind of looking at
the asking the question so you what
happens after you digitize what is the
story that begins then so digitize not
as the end goal but it's sort of the
beginning of a new kind of internet
network existence for our collections
and we have a lot of material we're in a
kind of a massive data migration moving
our kind of knowledge base into the
networked environment we're just barely
scratching the surface at the moment but
what we're focused on it right now is
how to kind of prioritize move things
that have high engagement value high
research value and model Pratt processes
that can get more efficient and more
over time to kind of process material
more quickly the library as you can
imagine is going undergoing a profound
transformation right now moving from
stacks to server racks and underlying
all this kind of is it animating idea
for our work that's looking at the
institution in a different way looking
at not as kind of a
a closed repository or sanctuary but
more as an ode on a network so how do we
get our collections talking to other
collections to other institutions to
other kinds of information but for all
that it's not some glorious rapture
where we kind of lose our sense of place
we're still an urban library we're still
brooded in a city in a very specific
place with a very specific set of
concerns at a very specific history and
so what the story going to tell you now
is there at a certain a particular type
of collection maps and how we're trying
to get these maps talking to the places
that they refer to typically in the past
tense so as an example this street
corner in the West Village you wouldn't
know walking by at this corner of Sixth
Avenue and eleventh Street was once the
old grapevine tavern which is where
through the grapevine the expression
comes from it was sort of the local
gossip mill a place where artists
politicians bankers would kind of gather
and there was actually an old grapevine
growing on its side which kind of
superseded the original name and this
was the kind of the main information
provider of the neighborhood before the
near public library set up in the
neighborhood branches there so this is a
vanished place that you wouldn't
immediately have access to her knowledge
of in walking through those streetscapes
here to this in soho this stretch of
broadway right at prince street you
wouldn't know this but this was actually
the site of nibblers theater which was
actually it is it is generally agreed
upon the site of the first production of
the first American Musical or like book
based musical the black crook which is a
kind of a fantastical story of
Witchcraft and sorcery there actually
was a garden that was sort of the
entrances of Broadway went back to a
much larger complex and the very place
that I work is is a kind of a great
example of this kind of layer cake of
history this is a view of the year
public library more or less today here
it is in the in the 30s and this
actually before this was built in
nineteen eleven or the completed was the
mains the city's main water source it
was the cotton distributing reservoir
and actually my office which is a kind
of a new a more modern insertion into an
old open-air formerly open-air courtyard
you can still see some of the foundation
with that original reservoir so this
this this kind of a time travel is kind
of drilling down through the layers is
on our minds a lot and looking at how we
can build pull from some of our great
collection strengths among them being
New York City history and see how we can
get these materials talking to other
information spaces and actually make
these more than just kind of like a act
on this impulse of connecting these dots
also on this footprint behind the
library is the gorgeous Bryant Park this
used to be the site of the New York City
Crystal Palace which was kind of at its
time in the mid 19th century a kind of a
global exposition space that then
tragically burned down three years after
it was erected so the where do we find
the hooks how do we start to join these
pieces of information so we looking at
the maps the kind of map that is most
promising that we focus most of our
effort on are these atlases is produced
by insurance companies largely in the
19th century but going into the early
20th century these provide building
level detail of the city over different
time periods and they were they were
created with incredible accuracy and
fastidiousness because they were used to
calculate property values to manage risk
things were burning down all the time
and these maps provided keys they were
full of data color codings and other
markings that gave you information about
what the building was made of how what
kind of risk it was what its use type
was residential ritas commercial what
kind of things were being manufactured
there were they particularly flammable
and so you can see here this footprint
is the kind of the locus of the of the
stories I was just telling now about the
and there is the footprint of the
Crystal Palace that large kind of
circular blob and next to it the
reservoir so that's where I I work in
that footprint but of course is
inhabited by very different places so
we've been digitizing these maps for a
number of years and we put them online
as images of old maps and that's nice I
mean formerly you would have to come on
site to look at this in person and now
you can go to a web page and see an
image of the map
and it has a bit of descriptive metadata
usually not particularly helpful it'll
it will tell you the bounding streets as
you can see but it's not going to tell
you the interior street so it doesn't if
you're looking for those accustomed to a
kind of a very fluid geographic search
it's going to frustrate that you have to
kind of know how to query around the
edges literally of map plates because
maps have for a long time been stored in
codex form but this is clearly a step
forward but how do we turn the maps into
data how do we create a new collection
that is essentially a data set a set of
API is an ontology instead of hooks that
of places through time that other
information can be aggregated against
this is being done in the kind of
contemporary space the New York City has
a data portal a government data portal
eyes do increasing number of cities now
there's a movement opening up government
in government information and there is a
building footprint file from of today's
City and you there even have some basic
kind of visualization tools where you
can map these things in kind of a fusion
table it within their website and you
can start to look at the at the the
buildings of today cities parcel and lot
data but what we're really looking at
and what we see kind of trapped in these
maps in pixels once they've been
digitized is kind of a revision history
of that building footprint file the kind
of the changelog of the city's built
environment over a number of centuries
so how do we get these maps to be
queryable in the way that we have come
to expect of maps so again as I said it
begins with digitization imaging the
collections this is the kind of this is
where you have to begin and here's an
image of a page 1 of these insurance
Alice's they're very they're very lovely
and they very they vary a lot sometimes
revisions were a new section of a page
paste it over there's wear and tear
there's different kind of colors
slightly variations of the colors of
paint but the data is there next comes a
process that it's called geo
rectification or warping and a number of
years back we worked with some
collaborators kind of in the
OpenStreetMap community to build a tool
suite called map warper which is a set
of open GIS tools that are can be found
elsewhere and like
arcgis but are an open source stack and
something that we built for the use of
our staff and then also the public to
kind of help with this work and so it's
basically a matching of old maps and
contemporary maps and with urban maps
that were produced with this kind of
high-level detail it actually works
quite well you can find one to one
correspondence is set up a number of
control points and kind of rubber sheet
them together and so you can start to
look at the maps in their geographic
context this map once it's been all the
kind of non map material from the page
has been stripped away and cropped away
you have a map that is actually a
spatial asset can be viewed in the
spatial context so we've taken a big
step forward that we've gone from pixel
space to geospace then you can start to
stitch the leaves together and so you
start to see a pretty stunning
remediation of a collection here is an
1854 Street Alice describing the very
tip of met lower tip of Manhattan at the
battery up to 42nd Street right at the
top of that sheet i showed you with the
Crystal Palace in the reservoir and it's
stitched together as a quilt laying over
laid over the island of Manhattan so the
this historical these historical
documents are starting to kind of take a
new form that is a more more in sync
with the kind of information that they
represent and this is now a new kind of
library collection these can be exported
from the map warp or site as layers as
kml file so you can just open it in
Google Earth and start playing around
and playing with transparencies so these
there's a pretty low barrier to to to
you accessing these collections now so
the map the Atlas is now a digital asset
and spatial spatially aware asset but
the buildings are still locked in those
sheets so the next step is vectorization
or kind of tracing features from these
maps and there's a tool in the map
warper suite which is it works but it's
rather cumbersome and labor-intensive
and it involves literally tracing
polygons over footprints and then
transcribing a bunch of attributes that
are informed by the key of the map but
to tell you what the color codings mean
and then other information that you can
read very readily like the addresses and
street names so you can transcribe these
they get associated with a shapefile and
then suddenly you have a new spatial
asset a very granular one that's
associated with this larger map layer
and these two
come collections that can be exported
and visualized so this is the building
file almost complete at this point at
this export of that 1854 street atlas
and this also can be exported and looked
at in things like Google Earth it can be
mapped in Fusion Tables so there a
similar view that I looked at from the
New York City's contemporary data portal
here is the 1854 layer and you can see
right there the residential neighborhood
that is now in the on-ramp to the
Brooklyn Bridge so you can start to see
some of that then and now but what's
really interesting why do this there is
for urban history and other disciplines
there is a inherent value in having that
change log and just having the building
files as a data set in itself but what
gets really interesting and kind of
reimagining a library is how these
buildings can become in these places can
become hooks can essentially turn the
city into a kind of a catalogue
interface and we have started to
prototype basically a database of these
historical locations harvested from the
maps and other sources it's what is
often called a gazetteer and so this is
actually from our very rough prototype
of this the the record for that nib
loews theater location and there you see
its shape file extracted from a map and
this is the thing that we can start
eventually to hook other collections to
so you could eventually find a newspaper
archives about this location original
playbills of this musical I mentioned
the black crook and here's a kind of a
bit player from the production you could
even start to get electronic editions of
the libretto and texts that we've that
are performing arts curators have
produced so that's what we're kind of
imagined that's why we want to do this
to see if the city can really be turned
into an interface where you can sort of
at a time slider to the map and then
find related materials based on the time
in place and we have again a lot of
materials that we would like to
associate with there's old city
directories archival correspondence and
documents Ledger's newspapers image
collections and so on and so forth proto
street views etc so that's all why we
want to do this vectorization process
but as I said it's incredibly
slow and in approximately three years
with intermittent outreach efforts
because this is largely done by
volunteers we've gotten about 105,000
shapefiles extracted from from three
atlases sorry this is a font casualty it
says atlases below there that sounds
like a lot but it's really barely
scratching the surface in the kind of
the entire archive that we have so we've
been asking and the in our team is there
a way to automate this process can do we
is it do is this something really that
we have to get you know handcrafted
artisanal small-batch data production or
can we start to put computers to work to
do this so this is a picture of a member
of my team Mauricio gorrell though who
built all the applications i'm going to
be showing you and the process i'm going
to be showing from here on out and this
is actually him during a map hackathon
we we hosted a about a year and half ago
now where he was actually in that
pictures just starting to crack the
problem or address the problem that i
will now walk you through the how we
have we've approached and just as a side
note the the building files this is our
geospatial librarian curated from the
map division looking very model like
there and the shirt he's wearing is
actually the hundred largest buildings
from the 1854 street atlases kind of
unapologetically aesthetic treatment of
the data and we're interested in in even
in playful ways that we can engage the
public with merchandise and with other
things that can sort of tell the story
of this transformation of the collection
so just as a side note so he was looking
at one iteration later about three or
four years later an atlas that extends
from the from the battery to the lower
portions of central park from around
1857 1862 and we're looking at 159 map
sheets here in this initial experiment
so scripted together a bunch of
open-source processes scriptable tools
to kind of develop an image processing
work flow that could read these shapes
out of the maps that could automatically
extract the buildings and the basic
guidelines that that Mauricio applied
were because there's a lot of shapes on
these maps so you how do you find the
ones that are the building's basic he
applied some basic rules they're
completely enclosed by black lines this
might be a font casualty dash lines are
not walls
there's a kind of size the thresholds
small and large and finally the well I
mean actually been forgetting what the
fifth one is the point is what through
stringing together this workflow he got
some pretty impressive results so this
is the automatic output on one map sheet
and by kind of operating within those
you know not too small to be a building
not too large to be a building ignoring
the streets which are polygons on in a
given sheet and this is what we produce
so this looks promising this looks like
we're onto something here and what we're
essentially built is sort of like an OCR
or optical character recognition for
maps a way to kind of read the shapes
and turn them into machine readable data
but big surprise it's not perfect there
are it doesn't it doesn't catch
everything and it gets there's a lot of
junk in there in fact right here you can
see one kind of issue that we come
across is there's false negatives
there's like a whole row a block that it
basically missed for some reason or
another maybe because there was a little
gap in the lines or some discoloration
or imperfection in the page but we're
looking at something that looks pretty
good something we can work with so
knowing that the the vector Iser tool
can get this output overnight with a
whole series of Alice's and probably
much faster on a more powerful computer
or working part in parallel we can
crunch through a lot of maps very
quickly so then how do we deal with that
quality control so this brings the
fourth and final step of this journey
that I'm describing this digital life
cycle and it is crowdsourcing and we're
operating on the kind of the precept of
you know Clay Shirky cognitive surplus
that there's roughly a third of the
human kind of brain cycle that has not
spent sleeping about spent working what
is that applied to is it applied to
consumption or some kind of production
and a lot of kind of collaborative
knowledge efforts have tapped into that
kind of cognitive surplus to produce
things like Wikipedia open-source
software projects a more a more vivid
way because I think of illustrating this
is this frightening statistic it's even
a couple years old that every day of
every there's 300 rather every day or
every hour 16 years human life years are
expended playing angry
birds and this may have gone up and then
apply this to other games so what if we
could tap into even a sliver of this
kind of cognitive surplus the spare time
to invite the public to help us crunch
these large piles of data and we've been
doing this with other collections we've
doing it around transcription plot
projects we have very successful project
or on our historical menu collection
we're asking people to create a culinary
database by transcribing the dishes and
prices out of old menus it's produced
nearly 1.3 million dishes that and
they're available to be an API and data
exports we're prototyping a project or a
similar project around feeder playbills
to create kind of a knowledge graph of a
performance history from old playbills
at the performing arts library in our
system has been collecting for decades
so the way we did this for maps and for
these for these maps in particular sorry
about the font change there is our
project called building inspector so
building inspector mi piel org and if
the vector Iser process is kind of like
the OCR for maps for kind of urban
building level maps this tool is sort of
like the reCAPTCHA the kind of sneaky
little tool that's woven into
authentication interfaces that proves
that helps you prove that you're not a
bot and also get some validation of OCR
text processing for google is why they
bought this company so this is kind of
the reCAPTCHA for our veteran process
and the basic interface that we launched
with is a simple three questions around
a given polygon is it right is it
completely wrong or is it you know in
the ballpark but needs fixing and i'm
going to show you the kind of mobile
view it's just it's a it's a responsive
website so this scales down very very
elegantly to a small screen you still
need to have a network connection and
this is the kind of fluidity almost a
game like rip rip repetition that it
involves so this is just you know you
can reframe the map a little bit and
we're just asking you is it does it look
right is it totally wrong or does it Nia
fix it also allows you to kind of view
your progress and start seeing the
bigger picture and so there are
obviously quality control concerns
inherent in this process are we just
going to trust what one person's
verification of this polygon of the
spectre ization and output and the
answer is no we're modeling a process
out of the citizen science is
particularly out of the Zooniverse
project with some of you may have seen
where they put the same task in front of
multiple users and kind of let it
consensus bubble up from below just
through through scale participation so
there are kind of some mathematical
thresholds basically if three or more
users agree it's going to be kind of
trusted if there's not agreement it'll
kind of stay in the queue and still get
more inputs if it's really kind of a
kind of a split decision it'll go into
another queue that we're going to deal
with later and haven't figured out yet
but by and large this does kind of shake
out very well and here you can see this
is a view of a current sheet and
everything that has received consensus
by the crowd is a green the yellows are
still are the one consensus fixes and
then actually you can't see in view here
any Reds which would be the nose all the
consensus knows so that was the version
one that we launched last fall just on
is this polygon right or not version two
we started to kind of develop out the
workflow here so from the checking task
a consensus yes we'll send it into two
new queues where we're going to ask for
new kinds of data from the maps we're
going to ask you to type in the address
and we're going to ask you to kind of
identify the color and the color is
significant again because it gives us
information about the materials with
which of the building was constructed
consensus fixes will go into a fixing
tool and then once they've reached
consensus have been fixed they will go
into this esq and go into these two
other workflows footprints Marquez no
are we we bid goodbye to them and so we
relaunch the spring with three new tasks
that start to animate this workflow so
here is the fixer can't ask it's just a
polygon editor and it actually works
well very very fluidly in this small
screen we're really trying with this
project to also set a new standard and
interaction design for libraries the the
expectations of the public are rather
low as to the technical products and
design digital designs that are output
by public institutions especially
libraries and we've been really trying
to kind of
change that expectation and kind of
surprised people with things that are
elegant fluid and really beautifully
interactive and kind of let the material
speak for themselves so that's the
polygon fixer the address tool looks
like this you just type in the dress and
you click an address and type it and
just all of it with sort of like a game
like flow that you can get into and this
is the color checker unfortunately not
very friendly to the two to the
colorblind but for those who can this is
another valuable in piece of information
that we're extracting from the maps and
there's an option for two colors so you
might be wondering will people actually
do this is this actually you know it all
looks very nice we've mapped out a nice
work flow there but is this something is
it really going to work so far with
actually fairly modest participation
because we're there's the library's
going through kind of a big web UX
alignment that's going to better surface
project like these we've been doing
these kind of a satellite projects and
having to build our audiences for them
kind of independently they're branded by
the library their embraced by the
library but they're not very easily
discoverable via the library's web web
sites which get a lot of traffic so
given those challenges we've still
gotten quite a respectable participation
and a really ecstatic public response
from those who participated just to give
a little bit of the kind of sentiment
from some of the tweets that we've been
getting so people seem to really dig
this and you know maybe we haven't
bested angry birds but someone is
actually compared us to flappy bird so
that is that I take that to be
incredibly encouraging and so far we
have logged as of yesterday over eight
hundred forty five thousand inspections
and again with pretty modest web traffic
web traffic in the tens of thousands and
we over over many months and so we're as
we kind of refine this workflow and kind
of really kind of keep trying to push
the envelope with interaction design on
these projects so kind of let the
materials speak for themselves and then
just have that task be very clear very
in focus and very repeatable very even
Pleasant and maybe even
dictating to do we we think that this
has a great potential to scale as it
gets woven into to the library's kind of
main kind of program initiatives and so
that and that is the aim so these
crowdsourcing initiatives we've been
kind of proofing them out for the last
few years and we hope to kale these out
in the years to come and the dream then
being of course coming back to my
initial story that will start to have
these hooks have a very well populated
date historical data set for the city an
ontology a set of hooks that because are
aggregating other materials around so
the city the library can really going to
become a time machine that can be
accessed programmatically or even in a
casual mobile interface browsing the
city and wondering what was in that
building what was on this place many
years ago and so up next to the project
we'd like to figure out an offline mode
so this could be done in the New York
City Subway our patron base is very
subway oriented and AD there isn't a
reliable connectivity in the subway at
this point and so being able to cash
maps check out a set and crunch that on
the subway and then check it back in
will be really I think put us in a kind
of more competitive position to the
flappy birds and angry birds of this
world so so that that's my story and
thank you for your attention